this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Anna
um today I'm going to be talking about
my ongoing project examining the
regulation of carotenoid content and its
interactions with carbohydrate
metabolism in cassava so Emily did a
nice job of setting us up for this one
thanks Emily
so cassava is known as a food security
crop because it's a really important
source of carbohydrates and calories for
many tropical areas of the world
um
it is rich in starch but not many other
micronutrients so as a result a lot of
populations that rely heavily on cassava
based diets tend to have micronutrient
deficiencies and
one of those in sub-Saharan Africa in
particular Pro vitamin A
deficiency is affecting over half of
children under five so it's a really
common deficiency among people who eat
cassava
um but there are varieties of cassava
that naturally accumulate some Pro
vitamin A content they have a yellow
pigment and that not only boosts the
nutritional quality but also improves
the post Harvest storage of cassava
so cassava breeders have been working on
improving yellow cassava to increase the
beta-carotene content which is Cleveland
have to produce vitamin A inside the
human body so it's considered Pro
vitamin A biofortified
and
um through recurrent selection breeders
have been doing a pretty good job at
increasing carotenoid content but it's
been difficult to combine high
carotenoid content with other other
favorable traits that are needed for
Consumer acceptance
in particular carotenoids are negatively
correlated with dry matter content and
so
um
this makes it challenging to combine
both High carotenoids and hydride matter
content which dry matter content is
essential for Consumer acceptance of new
varieties it influences the dry yield
and also the textural properties
so my project comes in to see how can we
improve both carotenoid and dry matter
contents
um
simultaneously in in cassava breeding
so for this it's important to know what
is the genetic relationship between
carotenoids and starch which are
negatively correlated so this could be
driven by linkage genetic linkage or
plyotropy
so in genetic linkage the hypothesis is
that there are two separate loci close
together on the chromosome one that
influences carotenoids and one that
influences starch and there are such low
side that have been identified in
cassava one is um the phytoise and phase
two allele which Emily introduce
phytoons in phase two is the rate
limiting step in carotenoid biosynthesis
nearby this allele there's also two
candidate genes for carotenoid for
carbohydrate
um synthesis including sucrose synthase
and so it's thought that there's a psy2
allele that increases carotenoids and a
linked sucrosynthase allele that
decreases starch
um there's also evidence that phytoine
synthase expression itself could also
affect carbohydrate metabolism so in
cassava and potato when Psy is
overexpressed there's a dramatic
increase in carbohydrates and a
concurrent decrease in starch as well as
a lot of other broad metabolic shifts
changes in carbohydrate metabolism fatty
acid metabolism
and Broad changes in gene expression
associated with those metabolite
pathways
and uh carbohydrate metabolism
metabolism is also affected in um
several other crops that have been
engineered to produce higher carotenoids
including tomato Citrus and Maize and
rice
so I think it's important to distinguish
between these two scenarios because if
we are dealing with genetic linkage you
could theoretically break the linkage by
continued breeding and continued
recombination potentially aided by
markers
if it is an inherent pyotropic
relationship that affects the metabolism
then you may need a metabolic
engineering approach to increase both
simultaneously or to focus on other qtl
besides the psy2 allele
so
um just briefly to mention some of the
hypotheses about how psy2 could be
plyotropically affecting carbohydrate
metabolism so one of the main hypotheses
of the authors who transgenically
modified the yellow cassava was that
this
ugps
UDP glucose pyrophosphorylase the
expression of that enzyme is being
affected by carotenoid accumulation
through an unknown regulatory mechanism
um there's also other hypotheses
involving the co-location of carotenoids
and starch in the same plastids so
carotenoids and starch are both
synthesize and amyloplas and precursors
for both those processes need to be
transported across the membrane so there
could be local competition for glucose
or ATP within the amyloplast or
Downstream products of beta-carotene
like obsidic acid could be having the
broader effects on metabolism
on the other side
um if it's true that genetic linkage is
mainly driving the correlation
um
then we want to understand how that
Locus is affecting the trait and also
what other loci are affecting the traits
that we can improve carotenoid content
without decreasing dry matter
so the distribution of carotenoid
content as estimated here by chromometer
B value it's bimodal
so the on the left there tens the white
cassava is generally considered to be
less than 20. and the yellow cassava is
generally considered above to have
higher cardamom content and we know that
that difference between white and yellow
is driven by the psy2 allele all of the
yellow cassava have at least one copy of
that allele and it's additive
there's also some quantitative variation
in carotenoid content within that yellow
cassava group and that's what I'm I'm
interested in looking at
so there's a range and gradient from
cream to yellow and within that there's
also some interesting spatial variation
so we have this fun phenotype called the
egg yolk phenotype where the center
tissue layer of the root is yellow and
outs or darker than the outside so it
looks like an egg yolk and that's one
example of spatial variation in
carotenoids that we know isn't caused by
the psy2 allele because it's happening
different accumulations that's happening
within the same genotype
so I want to use this system of the
inner and outer tissue layers to test
some predictions the first is that the
tissue specific carotenoid enrichment is
transcriptionally regulated so I want to
see what genes are upregulated or down
regulated in the center layer that's
enriched with carotenoids compared to
the outside
and then I'm also predicting that if
there is an inherent metabolic trade-off
between carotenoids and carbohydrates
then that would I would expect that to
persist across spatial and environmental
variation as well as genetic variation
so if there's an inherent trade-off for
the plant only has so much resources it
can transport into the middle class if
it's focusing more on carotenoid
biosynthesis in the internal tissue
layer I expect that internal tissue
layer to help lower dry matter content
so to test some of these predictions I
set up a greenhouse experiment and the
main objectives of this is to understand
the regulation of carotenoids beyond the
psy2 locus looking at the quantitative
variation and also to test hypothesize
interactions between carotenoids and
carbohydrates
so for this experiment I have in the
greenhouse a set of 54 accessions there
are five of them come from Africa five
of them come from Colombia and then the
rest are hybrid crosses between them
and I've grown these in greenhouses in
pots
measure the crotoid composition measure
starch and sugars and I'm working on
extracting RNA for three prime rna-seq
I'm repeating that trial with a subset
for a second year and I'm going to
harvest at different time points and
then do an expression analysis I'll talk
more about
so for the metabolite quantification for
these cassava samples I separated them
into inner and outer tissue layers using
this makeshift cork board and then um
biophilized the tissue and so measured
dry matter percentage by the dry weight
divided by the fresh weight
I extracted and measured carotenoids in
Ted tanhauser's Lab at the USDA with the
help of Terra fish
and so we measured those with uplc UV
VIs
and I'm working on measuring starch and
sugar with colorimetric assays
so from this preliminary trial in 2021
we first just grew out the seeds so that
we could get them all in a clonally
propagated stay and did an initial
characterization of the germplasm and we
did see a negative correlation here
between total carotenoids and dry matter
content
and so that was that was good
we also saw that there was variation in
carotenoid composition
so
um we noticed that the African sava
lines tended to accumulate more of these
precursors the phytoine phytofluene and
the Latin American varieties tended to
accumulate more of the violaxanthin and
lutein and most of the variance is
explained by variation in trans
beta-carotene which is the major
carotenoid compound to cassava
so then we propagated this trial and
replicated it in 2022
and I was surprised to see that there
was basically no relationship between
carotenoids and dry matter in this trial
um if anything it was slightly positive
and the heritability for carotenoids was
relatively High 0.8 it was pretty low
for dry matter 0.175 so there's a lot of
things that could have been different
between this trial and the last
preliminary trial there are different
greenhouses different pots different
replicates and of course we separated
these by tissue layers where we didn't
separate the other one
so I'm there's some environmental
variation going on here for sure between
the first and the preliminary trial
um but I was interested to see that in
this case there is no apparent
correlation
um looking at the tissue layer I saw
that the relationship between
carotenoids and dry matter differs
depending on which tissue layer you're
looking at so in the inner layer it is
negatively correlated
um but in the outer layer it's actually
positively correlated
so perhaps the developmental stage of
the root is really important and if you
see that overall correlation because it
might depend on the ratios of the inner
and outer tissue layers and how big
those are and how much you sample
so moving forward I'm going to sample at
different time points so I can try and
capture the growth of the root and how
that changes over time
I'm also working on doing rna-seq to
from the inner and outer tissue layers
um between inner and outer tissue layers
I want to look for differentially
expressed genes so I'm looking for genes
that are expressed in the enriched inner
tissue layer that might give us a clue
about how carotenoids can be increased
in cassava and what genes are important
um second I want to look for trait
Associated genes so those are
transcripts that are associated with
quantitative variation in carotenoid
composition as well as
amounts so we want to maximize
beta-carotene since that has the highest
provide money activity
um and then I want to do a network
analysis to look at the co-express gene
modules and identify if there are
carotenoid and carbohydrate metabolism
enzymes in the same modules which would
suggest a plyotropic relationship
so right now we're growing the second
trial it's in the greenhouse
um where we use a subset of 20 genotypes
and they have been genotyped we're
harvesting them this summer at four
different time points and are going to
replicate the analysis
um from trial one with the metabolic
metabolites and rna-seq
and moving forward after harvesting
um that trial I'm also looking at doing
a multivariate g-was in the reading
population at The International
Institute of tropical agriculture so
that we can look across the genome and
across more genetic diversity at what
other loci might be affecting
carotenoids and dry matter either
jointly or independently
besides the psy2 locus
and then finally I want to synthesize
the results from that gwas with this
expression analysis to develop some
suggesting breeding strategies for
dealing with this trade-off in cassava
so that might mean developing markers to
help break the recombination to break
the linkage
um and screen for recombination it might
mean identifying additional qtl besides
the psy2 locus that don't have effect on
dry matter or perhaps identifying
metabolic metabolic engineering targets
and with that I'd like to thank
um my committee the tan Hauser lab the
guterman staff I've worked in several
labs to do this wet lab work the Soros
lab the G of Noni lab in the gore lab
and I'd like to thank our collaborators
next gen cassava and ieta who have
provided the materials and finally I
need to mention jiho Lee who's pictured
helping me harvest the cassava he's an
undergraduate student mentee who's been
helping me with this project last summer
thank you
Travis
didn't you mentioned this a little bit
Sarah but do you think it would cause an
effect that you're using this constant
size right for your separating to ask
foreign
if that has an effect maybe separating
the things that are certainly outer and
certain inherence out of state yeah so
the question was
um being certain about separating the
internet or tissue layers
um the way I've been doing this it's
definitely not exact
um
the way I've been separating the layers
sometimes it's you can see it visually
like there's a if the inner color is
different you can see where that line is
and I have different size diameters of
those pipes and trying to match the
closest one but it's not perfect
um and if I can't see the inner tissue
layer I guess based on the proportion
and other similarly sized ones what size
I use for them
um so it's not capturing like the exact
tissue layer but um
I think it's probably separating the the
general tissues enough to if there's a
different relationship to be able to
capture that
foreign
[Music]
yeah I'm mostly interested in the
spatial difference because it's that the
egg yolk phenotype has been something
that we know is not driven by psy2 but
we don't know what causes it
um there are other spatial variants like
if you go a long ways in the root there
there's some variants from like the
proximal to the distal end
um but I just decide to focus on this
one just because I I can't do too many
segments or I'll have a million samples
Emily
yeah it's in the coding sequence and it
changes the the catalytic um
see of the the psy2 enzyme itself
Matthew
um
being affecting
yeah the question is if I'm looking at
any plastic genes I'm definitely
interested in looking at the expression
of or
um I've seen in my
um I've done some microscopy on the
roots and I haven't seen clear evidence
of chromoplast but I have seen some
evidence of chromoplast so there's been
some I've observed some crystals forming
some carotenoid crystals which is
suggestive of at least
amylocromoplast but I guess the line is
quite blurry
um so I'm interested to see if I can
learn more about that looking at
expression of or
um and if you have any other Placid
Associated genes you know I'd be happy
to hear about them
Mike
a little pressure now
so uh is there actually a large variants
for Psy student plasma or is there
essentially only one Apple ID
um yes the question is if there's a lot
of variants allelect diversity with psy2
or if it's just that one haplotype I'm
only aware of that um one haplotype in
all of the yellow cassava sequences I've
looked at and I just looked at the
coding region and it is that same snip
but they're possibly other
um
Snips and other accessions I haven't
looked at or expression differences that
I'm not aware of
course
yeah so the the individual carotenoids
tend to all follow the same relationship
as total carotenoids which is mostly
beta-carotene I tried looking at all the
different components to see okay maybe
phytoine is negatively correlated or
something but they're all pretty much
following the total carotenoids
um is that answering your question
okay
[Music]
yeah so in cassava starch is the main
component of dry matter but there are
also other components like fiber and so
that's something that could be affecting
um my I'm using dry matter here as a
proxy so I'm working on measuring
directly the starch content so I can try
and distinguish between starch or sugar
specifically compared to other
components of dry matter
okay thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu